[Music]
The Wall Street Journal recently ran a
story headlined the new copycats how
Facebook squashes competition from
startups basically the tech giant's can
buy out any startup they want or
aggressively imitate them and drive them
out of business
how alarming should we find this well
judging by the growing number of voices
calling for regulating big tech from
Tucker Carlson to Elizabeth Warren I
think I'm supposed to be pretty alarmed
but what is the public policy problem
here acquisition is typically a good
thing for the startups themselves and
the startup sector is still pretty
vibrant the main concern seems to be
whether the market dominance of these
tech giants is a bad thing it's tough to
make that case from a consumer welfare
standpoint since most of these products
are free plus these companies are
certainly acting as if their dominance
is tenuous given how closely they track
their potential competitors in other
words the sheer size of big tech
shouldn't concern us too much longer
term it's their control of big data that
is likely to be with the antitrust
regulatory battle raging to learn more
about my take on regulating big tech
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you
want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI